because once you give up you're just
waiting to die you know you want nice
quiet stay at home with Grandma pour
another glass of water and put her false
teeth in it in that way one and one can
equal three that it doesn't matter who
you are your dreams can't come true
everybody's in one business the people
business
it says music business it doesn't just
save music give me a new maze every day
my most profitable venture is gene
Simmons I want to I wanted I want it all
we all have our crosses to bear so what
get over it he's a rock star singer
songwriter entrepreneur and television
personality he was known as the demon
and the co-lead singer of KISS he has an
estimated net worth of over 300 million
dollars
he's gene Simmons and hear his top ten
rules for success because you want
inspiration look to your mother you bet
don't listen to the self-help gurus and
the people stuff even though I get paid
a lot of money to do this stuff myself
turn around and look at your mom that's
the most inspiration that's the reason
you should go out there and strive I
remember the first ten million dollar
check I ever made and it came in at one
lump ten million dollar check and I gave
it to my mother and I said mom look cuz
you know I want my mom to be really
proud and she said in her broken English
we're gonna hold on a second and she
said in her broken English van therefore
because she that's you know she's
Hungarian wonderful Deaconess scholar
that's Greek wonderful now what are you
going to do that's precisely the point
you did well now go on if you're the
fastest human being in the face of the
planet when all the cameras leave and
when the girls stop kissing you and you
put the award away are you going to get
up the next morning when when the Sun is
just coming up and all by yourself try
to break your own record even though
you're the fastest on earth the idea is
shouldn't life be about striving there
is no such a thing as winning there's
only doing better than you
before because once you give up you're
just waiting to die the staying power
means hard work staying power means
every day you get up and you try to have
a stay away stay ahead of the pack and
sort of march to the beat of your own
drummer this notion that music becomes
Majin eyes in other words there are lots
of successful rappers that have short
careers because if you can replace one
rapper for another you're done the more
unique you are and what you do the
better your chances are continuing on so
when you take a look at that sometimes
it's musical take a look at a band like
ac/dc
you hear it you immediately know what it
is that's what they serve up you want
balance go to another band they serve up
straight it that's what you do
kiss serves up spectacle we will not sit
around on stage on a Persian carpet
light candles and sing about how the
flaxen-haired lasts and the English
countryside kill me now
we don't do that you know you want nice
quiet stay at home with Grandma pour
another glass of water and put her false
teeth in it let the spinach rise to the
top that ain't what we do we blow stuff
up with a drummer and a backbeat and
don't sing about the secret of life
because there is none here's the secret
of life you're alive and then you're not
that's it
that's the secret be glad you're alive
while you're alive you're allowed to
shake the world up a little bit and
that's what you do
Partners are one of the most important
assets not detriments assets partner up
with somebody who knows something you
don't
in that way one and one can equal three
hang out with smarter or better looking
or more successful people than you are
they'll take you up you think Paul
Stanley's better-looking than you all
Stanley is a much better looking guy
than I am much more creative and those
things I will never know
and likewise for myself in regards to
him 1 in 1 equals 3 we've been together
over 40 years and where we sit now kiss
out selves The Beatles and Elvis we have
more licensing and Merchandising
products than almost any band out there
which is to say we have a kiss Golf
Course in Las Vegas and we're going on a
kiss Cruise in about a week when I first
came to America of course I couldn't
speak any English and I went to see
Pinocchio I thought the music was great
and this little puppet boy I immediately
connected to him is Pinocchio kid all of
a sudden is little cricket
this Jiminy Cricket character comes in
like the Messiah and looks at the movie
screen that starts singing when you wish
upon a star your dreams come I thought
he was singing to me
I thought Oh gene this is for me and I
could understand the words enough that
it doesn't matter who you are your
dreams can't come true how do you know
what's right to create for in a sense
the merchandizing word how do you know
what's going to work what's not where
you don't you don't you learn to listen
people will tell you what they like
which is why it's an it is an
interesting example of what I'm talking
about Steven Spielberg who I've met and
listened to obviously is the most
successful film maker of all time he
makes every single one of his movies has
made at least a hundred million dollars
without fail nobody is equal that record
and he's done everything from Jewish
concentration camp stories to aliens
from other worlds to color purple to all
kinds of stuff every single one has made
a hundred million north what he does is
he makes a movie his way he's also part
owner of DreamWorks
nobody's gonna tell him what to do how
to think how to edit but he does a
strange thing after he gets his movie
exactly the way he wants it he will take
his movie and go to hip slanty Michigan
and he'll sit down with people who were
completely unqualified pretty much to do
anything especially tell him how to edit
his movie and he will listen to them
with what's wrong with his movie they'll
say I didn't like the ending I don't
like that person I don't like that actor
and then he goes back and he changes it
he listens to the most unqualified
people because ultimately you PBS kiss
everybody is in one business the people
business and no matter what we think of
them whether they're the great American
you know populist or the unwashed masses
you can make any point of reference you
like they're the bosses we just work
here the history of kiss pretty much
started like any other band for
knuckleheads off the streets of New York
who had big dreams of becoming sort of
the American version of the Beatles on
steroids
I was always trained as a young child to
go to school and to learn and to read
voraciously even subjects I wasn't
interested in so when we first started
putting the band together I read
Billboard magazine a record world and
cashbox
the weekly Bibles of the business of
music and if you believe in full
disclosure and advertising it says so
right away it says music business it
doesn't just say music so I recognized
that it was a business and I was curious
how does it work what's the price of
goods where's the profit margin what's
the distribution method who what when
where and how my mother continues to be
the greatest inspiration which is if you
take away all your stuff could you do it
again in a different field see so I'm in
a band and I have a restaurant chain
called rock and brews which is at Los
Angeles in Nashville and Kansas City
Maui combo every its exploding and I own
a football team the only one in Los
Angeles called LA kiss we're on CBS
sports ESPN
and all that stuff Brandon licensing
merchandising kiss is celebrating our
40th anniversary and boy do I look good
we continue to tour the world I leave
Friday from New York and go to Mexico
City where we're going to be playing the
stadium there the day after I go to
Phoenix to continue with me ink
promotion and stuff then hop on to the
Bahamas for the kiss cruise where 4000
or 5000 crazy kiss fans pay about five
grand apiece
let me see that's twenty to twenty five
million gross we take 70% and then I
goes into a Vegas residency in other
words the band would be enough for
anybody thought I'm voracious that's a
big word like gymnasium I want to root I
want to read everything I want to learn
stuff I don't know because you know the
the mouse when it first starts to learn
how the maze works is alive because you
don't know where you're going and it's
the hunt you know not to kill and that's
a killer Mouse that's going it finally
gets to the cheese now unless and if
that maze continues to change that Mouse
is going to take its time and get fat
bloated and lazy and finally get to the
Chi because it knows where it's going
give me a new maze every day I don't
want to I don't want to get I don't want
to lose my killer instinct you know so
every day as far as I'm concerned should
be a new me Inc new me incorporated
because I am the business what would you
say your most profitable venture is
right now my most profitable venture is
gene Simmons investing in yourself yes I
don't know your product well they say I
invest in myself I never use capital to
invest in other areas I mean I'm in the
stock market and so on but I'm very
conservative but with myself anything
I'm passionate about
I'll throw capital at and any new
venture I'm involved in I'm totally
committed to because I know I never look
at the clock
how do you juggle the acting in the
musical careers which takes precedent I
don't think I take president
whether it's now or later I mean there's
time to do everything a lot of people
don't understand it but that's okay
because other people don't have they
have limited visions limited dreams
people sometimes only want to be a
successful doctor or so that's all I
want us to be a doctor well I want to I
wanted I want it all you went to school
in South Williamsburg have you been back
recently oh I did worse than school
there I went to yeshiva I was a Hasidic
Jew you know Hassid him but I don't
believe him yeah uh I know I don't look
like I come from Sweden but when I first
came to America
my mother wisely wanted to keep me off
the streets because in Williamsburg that
was the Williamsburg Dragons and it was
a street gang made up of guys and I
never heard of Christ or anything like
that and I started in broken English and
stuff at night if I stayed out there
longer than 10 p.m. I'd hear Christ
killer never heard of Christ didn't know
what they were talking about but they
were coming after me you know trying to
do some harm just because of my
religious beliefs you know I was a Jew
wasn't popular then still not a popular
thing but by the way it's not popular to
be a woman everybody picks on it's not
popular to be black Hispanic we all have
our crosses to bear so what get over it
get over it cry over there there's a
puddle of water where everybody takes
their turn to say oh it was a good
everybody picked on me you're right the
world is an unfair place it's prejudiced
it's biased he will think I'm a Jew he's
gay all of you okay get over it now of
course it's tough when you're black gay
Jewish and let you know like a lot of
stuff Mike then you got a lot of stuff
and you can get over that too
everybody's got their stuff at least
America gives you a shot in this biased
racist world we have an african-american
president so you can do it
we may even have a female president next
time so cry to your mommy I don't really
give it just get out there and
you know the military's got a great
phrase shame on you if you don't get up
and be all that you can be can you
imagine if you don't live up to your
potential and I guarantee you that
there's greater greatness in you than
you ever imagined because once upon a
time when you were a little child did
you ever I'm making it up you're making
100 grand a year did you ever envision
more than that okay three three hundred
one hundred million a day I don't but
could you ever met when you were a kid
you couldn't imagine if I found a dollar
on the floor so so perception of wealth
and how you're doing in life is all
based on where you are and what you can
perceive and I'm telling you that the
future can be so much bigger and so much
greater for you thank you so much for
watching as we made this video because
partner office asked us to if there's
someone that you'd like us to profile X
please let us know in the comments below
and we'll see what we can do we'd also
love to know which one of gene simmons
top 10 rules meant the most to you leave
it in the comments below and we'll join
the discussion thank you so much for
watching continue to believe and we'll
see you soon